مرحبا بكم في هذه النافذه الانسانيه
الخاصه بتداعيات حرب اسرائيل على غزه على
مختلف الصعد سينضم الينا من ولايه اوريجون
مايكل فخري المقرر الخاص للامم المتحده
المعني بالحق في الغذاء وسنس الضوء على
الاحتياجات الانسانيه وانعدام الامن
الغذائي في القطاع نشير في البدايه الى ما
اعلنته وزاره الصحه بشان عدد الضحايا في
قطاع غزه ارتفع عدد الشهداء الى
2627 و عدد المصابين الى
6797 منذ السابع من اكتوبر الوزاره اشارت
الى ان 70% من الضحايا اطفال ونساء كما
قال المكتب الاعلامي الحكومي ان هناك 7000
مفقود تحت الانقاض او ان مصيرهم مجهول
بلغه الارقام وفق ارقام الوكالات الامميه
المتخصصه في غزه مليونان و400 ال شخص في
غزه يعانون من عدم توفر الغذاء ذاء
والدواء والماء مليون و800 ال نازح في
قطاع غزه منذ بدء العدوان في اكتوبر
الماضي مليون
و2000 شخص في محافظه رفح وحدها التي تشكل
الملاذ الرئيسي للمهجرين
15 مخبزا في رفح ودير البلح فقط
لكنها منتشره في رفح ودير البلح كما قلت
اي جنوب وسط القطاع ولكن هذا هو الرقم
لغزه كلها لا توجد مخابز تعمل حاليا في
شمال وادي غزه وفق المنظمات العامله في
المجال الانساني نعود الى السيد مايكل
فخري في اورجن سيد فخري كيف تقيم الوضع
الغذائي في غزه الان والحديث عن مجاعه
بشكل
واضح بناء على ما تفضلتم به واضح ان هناك
خطر المجاعه وما يحصل هو ان اسرائيل تجوع
الناس في فلسطين وتفعل ذلك باساليب متعدده
في التاسع من اكتوبر وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي اعلن انه سوف يفرض حصارا تاما
على غزه وفي الحقيقه عرقلت اسرائيل تدفق
الماء والغذاء والدواء والوقود هناك دخول
لبعض المساعدات الانسانيه ولكن تريدنا
التقارير بان هذه المساعدات لا تزال تعرقل
وتدخل ببطء كبير تصل الى من يجب ان تصل
اليهم ما فعلته اسرائيل هو انها دمرت
المنظومه الغذائيه في غزه وقد دمرت اكثر
من 22% من الاراضي الزراعيه في الشمال
وتدمر المزيد من هذه الاراضي مع انتقال
الناس الى الجنوب دمرت 70% من المسام
وبالتالي واو نقاط الوصول الى المسام
وبالتالي تحرم الناس من قدره الوصول
للغذاء ونرى ان الجوع والمجاعه انتشرت
سريعا في غزه لانه كان هناك اصلا حصار
عمره 16 سنه كان خلاله اناس يواجهون سوء
التغذيه ونقص الغذاء قبل الحرب والان مع
وصول الشتاء صار الوضع اكثر ترديا وما
نشهده الان هو خطر المجاعه اذا كانت لم
تكن المجاعه قد بدات
اصلا الان على الحدود المصريه على سبيل
المثال
الاسرائيليون لا يعترفون بانهم يمنعون
وصول هذه المساعدات والمصريون يقولون ان
الجانب الاسرائيلي يمنع وصول هذه
المساعدات ما الذي يحدث هناك بالضبط اذا
كان يمكن ان تشرح
لنا هذهه التقارير التي تريدنا مفادها
ان معب رفح الحركه فييه بطيئه جدا وان
فتره المعالجه للسماح بدخول الشاحنات
يستغرق وقتا طويلا اذا بحسب ما سمعناه في
محكمه العدل الدوليه يوم الجمعه القرار
الذي اتخذ طالب اسرائيل بان تتخذ تدبير
واجراءات للسماح بوصول المساعدات
الانسانيه لما صدر هكذا امر من المحكمه لو
كانت المساعدات اصلا تصل وكانت اسرائيل
تسمح بدخولها اعرف ان الوكالات الامميه
والوكالات الانسانيه كلها مستعده الناس من
كافه انحاء العالم مست
لدعم وصول سكان غزه الى هذه الاساسيات
وبالتالي يعود على اسرائيل ان تضمن وصول
فعلا هذه المساعده من ولايه اوريجون في
الولايات المتحده مايكل فخري المقرر الخاص
للامم المتحده المعني بالحق في الغذاء
شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا لكم مشاهدينا الكرام
ختام هذه النافذه الانسانيه وعوده الى
الزملاء في غرفه الاخبار لمتابعه هذه
التغطيه المسترا